this is the woman behind what is
arguably the most iconic theme song on
television
but did you know that this woman is also
responsible for some of the most iconic
songs on the radio in the last century
biggest hits would be uh september okay
what have i done to deserve this oh
that's a good one
stir it up from beverly hills cop that
one too
you're the best from karate kids i know
that one the color purple musical that's
a lot of songs i've written over a
thousand songs
i'm allie willis i am a
songwriters hall of fame grammy emmy
tony and webby award-winning and
nominated
songwriter artist director collector art
director
social artist
party thrower
most important one
i don't know how to do anything
i don't know how to play an instrument
read or write music
[Music]
i had seen
less than five musicals before i wrote
the color purple i'm best when i don't
know what i'm doing in that case she
really must not have known what she was
doing when she wrote i'll be there for
you the theme song for friends it went
on to land her an emmy nomination and we
lost to the theme from star trek voyager
i dare anyone to sing that now
it's like really compared to the friends
theme but
that's how it goes
nevertheless i'll be there for you when
done in pop culture history just like
ali's earlier big hit september by earth
wind and fire do you remember the 21st
night of september
love was changing the minds of
pretenders while chasing the clouds away
we very purposely wanted to write a
happy song and i don't think there's any
happier song than september
the beginning of 1978 i was on food
stamps medical assistants really as
close as you could be to welfare without
actually being on it by the end of the
year i sold 10 million records was a
surreal experience which my entire life
is so
[Music]
if i wasn't allowed to be creative i
would
shrivel up and die i think open the
coffin when you throw me in there that's
when i stop
though probably i'll still be like
banging the sides hearing some kind of
feet